la sucesión geométrica adn está definida
por la siguiente fórmula entonces bueno
veamos aquí dice que el enésimo término
será igual a 3 x menos dos tercios
elevado a la n un potencia y bueno dado
esto la pregunta es cuál es el quinto
término de la sucesión entonces bueno
como siempre te invito a que lo intentes
a que a que intentes averiguar cuál es
el quinto término de la sucesión dada a
esa fórmula entonces bueno para
averiguarlo podríamos usar esta fórmula
como ya lo dije hace cinco a que será
igual
entonces bueno donde yo vea una n en
lugar de poner n voy a poner 5 ajá voy a
reemplazar a la n con un 5 entonces a de
5 es igual a 3 x menos dos tercios
elevado a la n 1 entonces 5 menos un
potencia a eso es igual a 3 x menos dos
tercios elevado a la cuarta potencia muy
bien y eso a que será igual veamos
entonces observa que estamos elevando un
número negativo a una potencia par así
que nos dará un valor positivo
ajá por porque estamos elevando un
número negativo una cantidad par de
veces entonces será igual a 3 x
2 elevado a la cuarta potencia eso es
igual a 16 y 3 elevado a la cuarta
potencia eso es veamos tres al cuadrado
es nueve entonces tres al cuadrado por
tres al cuadrado
eso es nueve por nueve así que tres a la
cuarta es igual a 81 entonces tenemos 3
por 16 sobre 81 y yo sé que me va a
quedar positivo porque estoy
multiplicando un número negativo por el
mismo una cantidad par de veces entonces
bueno en este caso es 4 o lo que es lo
mismo estoy multiplicando 4 números
negativos juntos eso me dará un valor
positivo por lo tanto tengo 3 por 16
sobre 81 y eso es igual a 3 por 16 eso
es igual a 48 sobre 81 positivo entonces
terminamos el quinto término de la
asociación geométrica es 48 sobre 81
positivo y listo